[Musique]
alors nous ce qu'on vise pour votre
entreprise c'est clairement la catégorie
2 moi ce que je vise pour une entreprise
c'est un beau slogan parce que c'est ça
qui fait mordre donc on sait tous ce
dont j'ai trouvé un truc qu'on me dit ce
que vous en pensez sublime kebab c'est
sublime c'est simple efficace comme les
aspirateurs c'est une piste
concernant la localisation et il faut
choisir un lieu stratégique qui
répondent à une certaine catégorie
sociale donc pour moi je m'en excuse moi
j'ai déjà réfléchi à ça évidemment moi
je république la république et un kebab
il cartonne de fou il ya beaucoup de
passage et où il ya un local juste à
côté qui veulent se libérer moi je pense
que devrait prendre ça me permettrait de
ram a craint pour ses clients arrêtez je
suis plus connu que je n'aime pas ce
terme est toutefois un monde de requins
voyez comme ça on n'a pas le choix
qu'ai-je fait pour faire ça marche
la minorité rapporte
alors concernant la composition il faut
surtout tenir compte des nouvelles
sensibilités heureusement donc on a
pensé à remplacer la viande par un
mélange d'algues et les frites par des
turbans tu veux remplacer la viande par
des pas des algues
c'est pas des tortues qui vont commander
c'est des gens qui partaient jean qui
vont au travail qui ont des enfants
c'est des êtres humains comme vous quand
tu veux dire tu risquerais pas là des
étals dans un kebab des algues mais non
mais non mais non mais les gars
maintenant mais c'est pas comme ça la
vie les ailes pour ça l'argent l'étude
oui oui alors pour le prix on a étudié
le seuil de rentabilité je pense qu'à
partir de 13 euros 90 on peut dégager
des bénéfices
je serais heureux 90 kw à locquémeau
c'est paris tunis contre un mois j'ai
passé un truc si on part sur mon modèle
économique avoir garçons très sains le
kebab à un non sens jamais été fait dans
le panneau le même en france après
calais en fait j'aime à 20 euros quant à
eric besson kevin
très très bonne idée ça des jetons quasi
frère ma parole que tu viens tu paies
avec des jetons de caddies et après il
ya un système dont s'est accumulée
jetons ça fait de l'argent évidemment
là un aux rousses
ouais
[Musique]